The map you see is a map of the whereabouts of the ten largest
gold mining companies in the world till the year 2020.
This map was revealed in March 2021
by the Canadian data company ‘Mining Intelligence’.
Now, I want you to be all ears to what is coming..
First thing to be noted is that; these ten big companies together
produced about 780 tons of gold in 2020,
which is worth about $48 billion.
This means that they together account for 22%
of the total global production of gold in the same year.
Second thing to be noted is that; 3 of these companies are operating in Russia,
which is why Russia is considered one of the largest gold producers in the world.
Our main focus here is on the three large companies operating in Russia,
chief among which is the Russian gold giant Polyus;
the second is the Canadian Kinross Gold which major
production comes from Russia despite being Canadian as it
controls one of the largest Russian gold mines. this will not continue,
on April 5, it vocalled about selling its Russian assets to the
Russian gold giant Highland Gold for $680 million due to the difficulties
it is experiencing in exploring because of the Western sanctions on Russia
then comes the third company which is Russia's Polymetal.
Russia has one of the largest gold reserves in the world
with estimated reserves of 5,500 tons.
In 2021, it was the third largest gold producing country in the world
with approximately 310 tons of gold.
More than two-thirds of the Russian production comes from
the largest eight Russian gold mining companies that control
the largest gold mines in the country, led of course by the giant Polyus,
which alone produces more than 26% of the total
amount there, and then comes Polymetal.
Let's take a look at the 6 largest gold mines in Russia,
their locations and quantities of gold.
By the way, five of them are controlled by Polyus.
The largest mine is Olimpiada, located in the Krasnoyarsk region in eastern Siberia.
It is the largest gold mine in Russia and the third largest gold mine in the world; owned and operated by Polyus.
The second mine, Kupol, is located in the Chukotka region in the
far east of Russia and is currently managed by the Canadian company Kinross Gold,
and its operating costs are among the lowest among the mines operated by the company over the globe.
The remaining four mines are all under polyus control, starting
with Russia's third largest, Blagodatnoye, located just 25
kilometers from the Olimpiada mine.
Then Natalka, located in one of the coldest and most remote areas
in the north of the Russian Pacific coast in the Magadan Region,
was acquired by Polyus in 2008. Then comes Verninskoye which
is located in Bodaybo, a historical gold-mining city in the Irkutsk Oblast in Southeast Siberia.
Last but not least comes the sixth mine which is the Sukhoi Log,
one of the largest untapped gold deposits in the world and one
of the most important projects of the Russian gold giant Polyus.
The mine is a valley, its name means the Dry Valley.
It covers 105 thousand square kilometers in the Russian Irkutsk region.
It has reserves of 2,000 tons, which is an enormous amount of gold,
and its life span extends to 35 years.
The mine is still fully operational in 2026 and it is expected
that Polyus will produce about 50 tons out of it annually, thus it
will be the second largest open-ended gold mine in the world
in terms of production after the giant Muruntau mine in Uzbekistan.
Obviously, gold is one of the most important natural resources owned by Russia.
That is why it is an important and significant piece of chess in the ongoing conflict between Russia and the West.
After the Russian army entered the Ukraine, Western countries imposed all forms and types of
sanctions that can be imposed on the Russian economy, as all of you know.
Some important questions must be asked here:
Did Russia really peg its local currency, the ruble, to gold?
Why did it do that? What is the effect of such a step? What does
it mean that the Western countries have banned dealing in Russian gold to the extent that there
are companies that have hundreds of tons of gold without a way to unseat them?
Now, I want you to be all ears to what is coming
Do not forget to subscribe to the channel.
I am Ashraf Ibrahim and this is the ‘Economic Informant’….
This episode is sponsored by INFINOX, a licensed platform that can trade gold, oil, forex pairs, cryptocurrencies, and more.
They have a copy trading app, IX Social, so you can follow top traders and copy their performance.
If you create an account using the link in the video description or Facebook comments, you will
get a 20% bonus on the deposit with $2 cashback on any forex trade.
Open an account and take advantage of the offer.
In April 1999, Switzerland abolished the de facto gold standard
that had supported its local currency in accordance with the constitution.
The Swiss franc has been linked to the euro ever since. Thus,
Switzerland was at that time the last country in the world to abolish the gold requirement to support the country's currency.
However, on March 25, the Central Bank of Russia announced
that between March 28 and June 30 it will be buying gold at a fixed price
of 5,000 rubles per gram, which is almost equal to $52
according to the exchange rate between the dollar and the ruble.
On the 7th of this month, it stated that it would continue to buy gold in rubles, but at a negotiated price; not fixed.
Definitely, the ruble rose in value against the dollar as a result.
At the day of this announcement, on March 25, a dollar was worth 102 rubles,
currently at the time of writing the episode, on April 15, one dollar is worth 80 rubles.
Thus, the ruble went back to its value before the Russo-Ukrainian war that broke out on February 24.
Buying gold in rubles is an extension of a series of measures
taken by the Russian Central Bank to support the ruble and
prevent its devaluation. This decision comes immediately after the 'buy Russian gas in rubles' announcement on March 23.
It seems that this will not be the last Russian commodity to be circulated in ruble.
We might be witnessing Russia selling oil, wheat, aluminum and other commodities that it exports in rubles, in the coming days.
The underlying mechanism here is to circulate commodities in ruble
Russia gives further more value to its currency globally
through creating a demand to ruble in the exchange market all over the world.
This goes, of course, in line with its attempts over the years, together with China,
to weaken the dominance of the US dollar on the global economy,
one of the reasons for which is that most international commodities are priced in dollars.
Let's focus on buying gold specifically in rubles. As noticed, Russia has set a time period for buying gold in rubles,
lasting only to the end of the next June, after which we do not know whether it will be renewed or not.
What I want to say is that such a step, although it greatly supported the ruble,
if not implemented well, will turn against Russia. Therefore, setting the time
period for the purchase of gold in rubles by the Central Bank of Russia was a smart move.
Why is it dangerous and may turn against Russia making the ruble lose its value?
Let us first and quickly explain the Bretton Woods system, how did it go!
After WWII, in the year 1944, all the major countries in the world were suffering the losses of the First and Second World Wars,
except for the United States as it controlled two-thirds of the world’s gold at the time
along with a strong and coherent economy unlike the rest of the countries.
The US thus insisted that the gold along with the American dollar must be the centerpiece of the Bretton Woods system that
was agreed upon according to the United Nations Monetary and Financial Conference or the Bretton Woods
Conference at the time. An ounce of gold has been determined ever since to be equal to $35.
Accordingly, most countries of the world have fixed the values ​​of their currencies on the US dollar as the United States was
guaranteeing all countries the convertibility of the dollar into gold and vice versa.
However, due to the US involvement in Vietnam, the increase in public debt, the negative balance of payments
and the intensive US printing of dollars to pay government expenditures on military and social programs;
many countries began to worry as the dollar may lose its value, so they began exchanging it from the United States for gold.
As a result, US President Richard Nixon issued a package of economic measures in 1971,wherein he feared that gold would run out of the United States,
on top of these measures, ending the convertibility of the dollar to gold unilaterally without consulting any country,
As for buying gold in rubles, Russia must abide by the same rules,
which is the convertibility of rubles into gold and here is the problem.
Russia may find itself in a similar situation to that of the United States in 1971.
If investors or the public lose confidence in the ruble for any reason, there will be a bank run to the Russian Central Bank
to withdraw the gold and replace it with the ruble. This as a result
would lead to serious problems in Russia such as economic instability.
As we know, after the imposition of Western sanctions on Russia, which caused the worst
economic crisis for the country since the fall of the Soviet Union in 1991,
families began to get rid of the collapsed ruble and buy gold instead.
Therefore, the Russian Central Bank stopped buying gold in mid-March
in order to give people the opportunity without crowding out. This was also a smart move by the Russian Central at the time.
That is why it has set a specific time period for buying gold in rubles, as we previously  said.
Gold for Russia is the type of assets that it can sell to support the ruble.
It is one of the main assets that the Russian Central Bank can resort to
to ease the crisis and absorb the effects of Western sanctions,
therefore it is an important and decisive weapon in the confrontation with the West in general.
Since 2014, as the United States and Europe imposed sanctions on Russia in response to the annexation of Crimea,
Russia began to make its economy more resilient in the face of sanctions and strengthen its defenses against
economic restrictions through hoarding gold and foreign exchange reserves and diversifying away from the dollar.
For this reason, we note that Russia's gold holdings have tripled
than they were during its annexation of the Crimea 8 years ago.
In numbers, in March 2014, gold accounted for 8.9% of Russia's total foreign exchange reserves.
In the last published data of Russian reserves on the website of the Central Bank of Russia
on January 31, 2022, the proportion of gold constitutes 20.9%.
How much gold does Russia currently have? Russia has the fifth
largest deposit of gold in the world. A senior White House
official said that before Russia invaded Ukraine, it had about
$140 billion US $ in gold, in other words; about 2,300 tons of gold
are currently in the possession of the Russian Central Bank.
This is in addition to the annual production that will join this
amount to reach 330 tons of gold by the end of the current year.
That amount alone is equivalent to about $20 billion today.
Of course, the sanctions imposed on Russia isolated it from
major parts of the global financial markets and froze nearly half
of its foreign exchange reserves, equivalent to $300 billion,
specifically foreign currencies such as dollars and euros that were in Western banks.
However, the 2,300 tons of gold were originally in Russia
therefore Western countries could not control or freeze them.
That is why this stock of gold is what is left over from foreign reserves,
in addition to about $100 billion US dollars between Russia and China.
That’s why gold is of value for Russia, yet, in order to be able to benefit from this treasure,
it has to move it beyond its borders in order to sell it. That is why
the United States, Europe and their allies moved quickly to block this hole, targeting Russia's giant gold stockpile.
On March 24, the United States announced, along with the Group of Seven industrialized countries
(which includes other than the United States: Canada, France, Germany, Italy, Japan
and the United Kingdom, in addition to the European Union allies) to ban dealing with Russian gold.
The US Treasury, for example, has issued a directive stating that any gold-related transaction
of the Russian Central Bank is covered by existing sanctions.
This was the first ban on trade with Russia linked to the gold markets.
On the same day of the ban, British Prime Minister Boris Johnson said there were indications that Russia was using its
gold to evade sanctions, and that Britain would take steps to ensure Russia could not sell bullion. The ban on Russian gold,
of course, was preceded by sanctions and restrictions on Russian gold companies by Western stock exchanges.
For example, on March 7, the London Bullion Market Association, or LBMA for short, suspended six Russian
refineries for refining precious metals, which means that they will not be able to sell either gold or silver in the London market,
which is the largest gold market in the world. Few hours later, CME Group, which runs the largest US gold exchange,
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange, also suspended six Russian Dahab refineries.
Therefore, the sanctions imposed on Russian gold prevent individuals, including gold dealers, distributors, wholesalers,
buyers, and financial institutions, from buying, selling, or facilitating transactions related to Russian gold,
whether from the Russian Central Bank or Russian companies themselves.
This ban is not limited to Western countries, it threatens any entity in any country (has the intention to deal in Russian gold)
with secondary sanctions even if it is in a major country allied with Russia like China.
So, does this mean that this 2,300 tons of gold has no advantage?
Will Russia be not able to deal with any part of it or sell it outside its borders?
In theory, yes, it has no value according to the current situation, however in practice and on the ground, Russia can use complex,
dangerous and difficult-to-track schemes to truck gold abroad away
from the United States and Western countries. Nevertheless,
this action movie needs an independent episode. If you want us to talk about how it is possible for Russia to smuggle its gold in
ways that are difficult to follow, as other countries have done before, like Iran and Venezuela,
please type to me down in the comments.
Don't forget to subscribe to INFINOX through the link in the description
In the end, if you like the episode: like, share, tell your friends about us, they may benefit too.
Finally, subscribe to our channel if you are not yet, Goodbye.